До світової спадщини ЮНЕСКО належать
видатні природні та культурні цінності майже 200 країн.
Їх визнано надбанням усього людства.
З 1990 року до цього переліку внесли і
сім українських об'єктів: храмів, резиденцій, давніх лісів.
Окрім того, ще три елементи належать до
репрезентативного списку нематеріальної спадщини людства.
Україна входить до списку країн
зі світовою спадщиною ЮНЕСКО.
Отже наша архітектура, пісні, кераміка,
праліси, видатні культурні та природні цінності
вже належать усім поколінням людства.
10 об'єктів, якими опікується ЮНЕСКО в Україні.
Перший об'єкт – історичний центр Львова та собор Св. Юра.
Архітектурні та культурні звичаї Європи
залишили помітний слід у Львові.
Разом із тим це місто має самобутні українські традиції.
Воно було засноване у пізньому середньовіччі
і завдяки вдалому розташуванню
стало успішним політичним і комерційним центром.
До найстарішої частини Львова належать
Замкова гора з рештками замку та околиці,
де система вулиць і площ сформувалися ще у 13-17 столітті.
А середмістя гармонійно поєднує сакральні,
громадські та житлові будівлі у стилях ренесансу і бароко.
ЮНЕСКО визнала Львів світовою культурною спадщиною,
бо це місто є видатним прикладом поєднання
архітектурних і мистецьких традицій Східної Європи
з традиціями Італії та Німеччини.
Його населяє низка самобутніх етнічних груп,
які створили у Львові окремі, але взаємозалежні осередки.
Трохи далі в середмісті, на пагорбі, розташований
бароковий архітектурний ансамбль собору Св. Юра.
Збудований у 18 столітті він поєднує у собі східно-
та західно-європейські традиції архітектури та мистецтва.
Цей собор був центром Української Греко-Католицької Церкви.
Другий об'єкт – Петриківський розпис.
Петриківський розпис – різновид народного малярства,
який виник у селищі Петриківка на Подніпров'ї.
Стіни, посуд та інші ужиткові предмети
тут оздоблюють фантастичними рослинними малюнками,
на які надихає місцева природа.
Частіше можна зустріти зображення
квітів та ягід, рідше – птахів, тварин або людей.
У 30-х роках минулого століття петриківські майстрині
налагодили у Києві промислове застосування розпису:
почали розмальовувати порцеляну і
наносити фарби на нетрадиційне чорне тло.
У самій Петриківці тоді відкрили спеціалізовану художню школу.
Нині тут діє Центр народного мистецтва,
куди приїздять повчитись та поспілкуватись із майстрами.
2013 року Петриківський розпис включили
до списку нематеріальної культурної спадщини людства.
Третій об'єкт – Козацькі пісні Запоріжжя та Подніпров'я.
Традиційні пісні, які виконували ще запорожці,
внесені до списку нематеріальної культурної спадщини.
І вони потребують негайної охорони.
Протяжні пісенні твори виконують гуртом,
переважно без музичного супроводу, рідше з бандурою.
Чоловічі, а нині все частіше жіночі гурти, співають про
козацькі походи та битви, життя окремих полководців,
стосунки між козаком і дівчиною.
При цьому не всі пісні, в яких ідеться про козаків,
можна вважати традиційними козацькими творами.
Козацькі пісні виконують переважно фольклорні
аматорські колективи Подніпров'я, окремі виконавці,
або ж люди, які збираються гуртом час від часу на великі свята.
Багатьом виконавцям від 70 років
і вони практикують цей спів більшу частину свого життя
і так зберігають зв'язок із минулим.
Утім їх щороку стає все менше.
Тому козацькі пісні потребують документування
і збереження для нащадків.
Четвертий об'єкт – дерев'яні церкви
карпатського регіону у Польщі та Україні.
16 давніх дерев'яних церков,
вісім із яких розташовані в Україні і стільки ж у Польщі,
ЮНЕСКО визнала світовою спадщиною людства.
Це найкраще збережені сакральні споруди
традиційного типу зрубів у карпатському регіоні.
Вони зберегли свою автентичність, оскільки їх багато років
ремонтували звичними методами.
Завдяки цим церквам можна прослідкувати
місцеву будівничу та релігійну історію.
Дерев'яні храми виконані в архітектурних стилях регіонів,
де вони переважно розміщені:
гуцульському, галицькому, бойківському, лемківському.
Приміром, збудована ще у 15 столітті дерев'яна церква
Св. Юра у Дрогобичі під Львовом,
славиться унікальними збереженими стінописами та іконостасом.
Крім релігійних мотивів тут можна побачити
рослинні орнаменти та житейські композиції.
Вони показують, яким бачили світ жителі
середньовічних галицьких міст.
П'ятий об'єкт – Дуга Струве.
До об'єктів, що становлять цінність для всього людства,
увійшла і геодезична дуга Струве –
мережа вимірювальних пунктів, що дозволила майже
точно визначити форму і розміри нашої планети.
Вона закладена у 19 столітті і названа прізвищем
астронома та геодезиста німецького походження.
Дуга довжиною майже 3000 км простягається
через територію 10 європейських країн:
від узбережжя Баренцевого моря у Норвегії до берегів Чорного моря в Україні.
Вона складається з понад двохсот основних пунктів, із яких
до списку світової спадщини входять 34 найкраще збережених.
В Україні їх чотири.
Три з них на Поділлі, а один – на Бессарабії.
Результатами вимірювань дуги Струве
користувались до кінця 20 століття.
Їх вдалося покращити лише завдяки
сучасним супутниковим дослідженням.
Шостий об'єкт – Косівська кераміка.
У Косові і довколишніх гуцульських селах виникла
традиція косівської мальованої кераміки.
Тут покриті білою глиною вироби
розмальовують лише трьома кольорами –
зеленим, жовтим і коричневим, – що символізують
відповідно гори, сонце і землю.
Сюжети на іграшках, посуді або цегляних плитках
зображують історію, побут, вірування і звичаї гуцулів,
а також навколишню природу.
Побачити косівську кераміку можна в окремих залах музею Гуцульщини.
Традиція розпису зберігається і розвивається в гуцульських селах і по нині,
завдяки дрібному виробництву і приватним майстерням.
Навчають цьому і молодь у косівському коледжі.
Сьомі об'єкти – Києво-Печерська лавра та Софійський Собор.
У 1990 році вони стали першими українськими об'єктами,
які внесли до переліку світової спадщини ЮНЕСКО.
На багатьох знакових зображеннях Києва можна побачити
величний золотоверхий монастир – Києво-Печерську лавру.
Вона була заснована за часів князя
Ярослава Мудрого у розквіт Київської Русі.
До складу лаври входять два унікальні підземні комплекси,
монастирські будівлі, церкви і дзвіниці, оточені оборонними стінами.
Упродовж тривалого часу цей комплекс був одним із найважливіших
християнських культурних та паломницьких центрів у світі.
У лаврі досі є чинні храми, монастир,
духовна академія та резиденція митрополита.
Також на цій території є Києво-печерський історико-культурний заповідник.
У тутешніх музеях можна побачити старовинні рукописи,
ікони, вишивки, гравюри та багато іншого.
Як і лавра, Софійський Собор був зведений
у Києві в 11 столітті, незабаром після хрещення Русі.
Він мав вплив на вигляд храмів східної Європи.
Вважається однією із головних пам'яток архітектури
та монументального мистецтва того періоду.
А до 13 століття був головним храмом
столиці християнського князівства.
Софійський собор та прилеглі чернечі будівлі збудовані
у поєднанні стилів: візантійського і українського бароко.
Там збереглися старовинні інтер'єри і
велика колекція давніх мозаїк та фресок.
Нині тут діє Національний заповідник Софія Київська.
Восьмий об'єкт – Букові праліси і давні ліси Карпат.
Україні вкрай пощастило з природними багатствами.
Первісні букові ліси Карпат входять до об'єктів світової спадщини,
що охоплює лісові масиви у 12 країнах Європи.
В Україні це 15 ділянок, які входять до складу
біосферних заповідників та національних природних парків.
Букові праліси є взірцем недоторканих екосистем
помірного кліматичного поясу,
де зберігся цінний генофонд лісового бука.
Саме такі ліси раніше займали 40% території Європи.
Їхні збережені ділянки дозволяють досліджувати
еволюцію бука та інших видів рослин з його ареалу.
У порівнянні з іншими лісовими об'єктами світової спадщини,
ці масиви мають унікальну флору та фауну.
Зокрема види, пристосовані до життя у печерах.
Дев'ятий об'єкт – Резиденція митрополитів Буковини та Далмації.
Не всі в Україні впізнають цю будівлю за назвою.
Однак всім кортить побачити
Чернівецький національний університет.
Навчальні корпуси тут розмістили лише в середині 20 століття.
А будували цей архітектурний комплекс у часи Австро-Угорської імперії
як центр Буковинської православної митрополії.
Резиденція складається з трьох монументальних корпусів:
митрополичого, семінарського
та монастирського, а також дендропарку.
В її будівлях поєднані елементи національної,
візантійської, готичної і барокової архітектури,
та мистецтва різних народів, які мешкали у цій місцевості.
Для зведення комплексу вирішили застосувати
тільки місцеві будівельні матеріали.
Настільки грандіозне будівництво спровокувало
створення низки підприємств у Чернівцях:
каменярського конвеєра, два цегельних
та одного керамічного заводів.
Особливо прискіпливо відбирали цеглу –
її перевіряли на звук.
Побачити пам'ятку ЮНЕСКО можна у складі екскурсій.
Їх проводять різними мовами.
Десятий об'єкт – Херсонес Таврійський і його Хора.
Більше двох із половиною тисяч років тому у південно-західній
частині Криму, на території сучасного Севастополя,
з'явилося дивовижне місто – Херсонес Таврійський.
До сьогодні береглися залишки античного міста,
а також його сільськогосподарська округа – Хора.
2013 року вони одноголосним рішенням
були включені до списку світової спадщини ЮНЕСКО.
Херсонес Таврійський був класичним грецьким полісом,
а також важливим політичним і економічним
центром північного Причорномор'я.
Тут підтримували культурний обмін із Грецькою,
Римською та Візантійською імперіями.
На момент російської окупації Криму 2014 року
у фондах херсонеського музею-заповідника
зберігалося більше 200 тисяч експонатів, знайдених під час розкопок.
Серед них – залишки оборонних мурів,
житлових кварталів та ремісничих споруд.
У період російської окупації Херсонесу,
як об'єкту світової спадщини, загрожує знищення
через використання у військових і комерційних цілях.
ЮНЕСКО – організація, яка прагне зміцнювати мир та безпеку у світі
через співпрацю країн в освіті, науці та культурі.
Програми спеціалізованої установи ООН спрямовані
на вільний доступ до інформації, міжнародну наукову співпрацю,
збереження і захист об'єктів матеріальної
і нематеріальної культурної спадщини.
Україна, як країна-учасниця ЮНЕСКО,
має безупинно рухатись у заданих організацією напрямках.
Нам є що розвивати, зберігати і любити.
[Ukraїner
ukrainian institute]